I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense it really started like back when
I was in college and I developed a drug
addiction and so I spent about five
years in school dropped out of school as
an addict and when I went into rehab
almost 20 years ago now I realized that
I had to change everything about my life
if I was gonna stay in recovery so I
started exercising I started going to
the gym I made a new group of
girlfriends who were into running and
other like healthy pursuits who actually
like talked about their feelings yeah I
changed my clothes I changed my job like
I changed everything and I really began
to pursue health and fitness through
that Avenue and I was very focused on my
athletic performance I was very into
CrossFit yeah a little bit later on and
so you know thinking about athletic
performance and recovery I remember
sitting around after a really difficult
Olympic lifting session and my original
is in their lives clean adjure know I
was like a look at we were at CrossFit
Boston yeah I didn't Kowski was teaching
us how to snatch know I learned that
Shanna can I suck at snatch I'm not I
mean I'm like five ten and a half we
would not get it all are really like
that but it was a really good session it
was a really hard session so we were
sitting around after eating and I you
know my original co-founder said to me I
wonder what would happen if we did this
like squeaky-clean kind of according to
like a paleo style diet anti
inflammatory approach for 30 days I
cleaned up just the last 20% because
paleo is so rooted in CrossFit like that
very much the adopted diet of cross it
was and this was back in 2009 so it
really was yep um and I like to Whole
Foods approach I was already doing
mostly a Whole Foods approach but at the
time that he's suggesting this I'm
eating Thin Mints right out of the
sleeve because I had just exercised and
I had earned them and I was like yeah
that sounds really good like let's do it
when do you want to start and he said
right know why don't we start right now
and I'm very like black or white on or
off the things that made me a good
addict to make me really good at these
kind of challenges so I was like cool I
handed my Thin Mints over and that was
really the start of the first whole
thirty back in April 2009 it was like a
personal self experiment how did you
create the guideline so we based it on
the framework of a Paleo diet which you
know was like meat seafood and eggs lots
of vegetables and fruit natural healthy
fats but I knew for me that there were
some other kind of interesting
pointing out the things you do get to
eat instead of don't I'm usually like no
grains no dairy no being snow right no
no no no no no no no there's no my first
rodeo I should have approached a good
job good job
cuz there's a lot of stuff you can eat
so those words totally we were focusing
on but I also knew that if I was allowed
to like recreate some of my comfort food
or technically compliant ingredients
that was B that would be problematic I
was also kind of obsessed with like the
scale and the mirror I didn't have
weight to lose but I was really obsessed
with like my body comp and was I getting
more muscular and was I getting leaner
like goal-oriented yeah food yeah but
not in a super healthy way like I had a
relatively dysfunctional as many of us
did growing up like relationship with
food and my body I think being a girl is
even harder too it's very hard it's
really hard and then I also had some
weird like body image issues based on
the fact that I was an addict and I was
like super skinny and not at all healthy
and like you know weak as a noodle so I
had a lot of stuff to prove I feel like
so this 30-day experiment helped
identify for me all the ways that I was
using food like I used to use drugs as
punishment as a reward to relieve
anxiety to self-soothe to comfort myself
but it also in like removing the foods
that I I couldn't turn to for those
reasons it helped me develop other
coping mechanisms and I finally felt
like for the first time I was able to
get off the scale and out of the mirror
it was really powerful what were your
other coping Magne talking to actual
human beings about how I felt I still
wasn't very good at it but it was like a
relatively new concept for me so that
feeling good just sitting you know
sitting in my feelings I'm not using the
gym for punishment the first two weeks
of whole 30 are a little bit rough in
that your energy can be down I was very
dependent on sugar and didn't realize it
so I couldn't go into the gym to beat
myself up so I would go for walks or
hikes and that felt like a nice or like
I guess you were a little little little
depleted yeah yeah so I I think I just
in the absence of realizing how often I
would turn to these foods you know I'm
having a bad day it's this I feel like
crap this I didn't have a good workout
this yeah it's just the awareness I
think was so important
you